je voudrais vous voir devant la première
diffusion de l'île aux enfants
le musée a fait son show télé pour cette
nuit des musées le thème était tout
trouvé
la télévision le sujet de l'exposition
temporaire du musée de la ville c'est
une proposition convivial et plus
festive que ce qu'on peut proposer
d'habitude dans un musée c'est
l'occasion de faire venir au musée et
d'un public de jeunes adultes qu'on
touche un peu moins peut-être que
d'autres établissements en
fonctionnement normal et la nuit des
musées l'aurait vraiment d'estimé des
improvisations de déclic théâtre des
visites guidées le temps d'une soirée le
public a délaissé sa télévision pour se
plonger dans l'histoire celle du petit
écran
c'est l'occasion de sortir le soir en
famille de visiter un musée dans un
contexte dans un contexte un peu
différent eh ben j'ai vu les télés
d'avant qui avait quitte pas du tout la
même chose que d'habitude c'est plus
pratique et aussi ses plus beaux parce
qu'elle n'était pas très bon été c'était
grosse pour partager un moment en
famille et puis c'est pas tous les jours
que le musée ouvert le soir donc c'est
bien c'est une bonne occasion de sortir
le soir dans un esprit culturel à 23h
fin des programmes le musée de la ville
a retrouvé son calme après avoir
accueilli 454 visiteurs avant la
prochaine nuit